your fever will go down. Inshallah, your
brace will be suppressed. If he does not
use the word inshallah, he's not a
practicing.
This is the difference. Another thing
you know
is
the pure
and you know the hadith of the beloved
prophet wasallam
when
the bedin when the Arabs when they go to
a village and they don't welcome them
and the leader of the tribe he is bitten
by a snake
And they ask him do you have any
treatment?
So the companions say that because you
did not treat us well you did not
welcome us we will charge you for the
treatment and they agree and they ask
for some flocks and they give it and one
of the sahaba he decides to surfy but
when they give the flocks they said no
first we'll ask the prophet is it
allowed for us
to take and make use of the flock. If
you're a Muslim, pray to Allah. If
you're a non-Muslim, okay, pray to God
that he is.
That's the reason why giving medicine
for a Muslim modern medical doctor, he
has to use the word insh. This is the
difference between the approach of
prophetic medicine to healing with the
modern medical treatment.
Yes. When I was doing when I was in
medical college, I had very few Muslim
colleagues who were doing the bachelors
for medicine.
More than 90% were non-Muslims.